hmm I'm back I love this subway it's
been so long let's find out the more
epic things - may some images they don't
need any other reaction that's all you
need
does it still work can you still play
supermario on that epically does that
work that's amazing
hey bro can I borrow your car sure bro
let me just strap these on alright
you're good to go man awesome thanks bro
oh poor dog the dog is literally me when
I see furries I go I don't like wear
normal clothes
ayyy hmm Brian look how much time I
spend on my computer what is this hmm
Jesus Christ it's like silic soft hmm
hmm
damn the chess equivalent of having a
way too big of a car epic compensating
for something there are we answered oh
Jesus thanks genius that really threw me
off it took me a while I'm like wait how
can Oh mmm actually whom in real life
how about that Wow mm-hmm professor are
you paying attention student wait I
thought this was art class oh sorry man
what it's a Photoshop right how's the
Photoshop battle whoo maybe I should do
that I'm not terrible at Photoshop okay
I'll do that in the future Oh
[Music]
I wonder what it shows up ooh what if it
like shows up you're his number so you
could be like hey lady
gee you are a code scan me that's right
you got my number
why does QR codes exist by the way they
do nothing for society pissed me off QR
codes how about instead of a QR code
just write your number then it's like
what's the point of it I don't get it
huh what mmm that's super him I'm
humming oh it's actually pretty awesome
mmm approved I'm approved yeah I've seen
this it's so confusing that actually
made me home for a second even though
I've seen it that's how horrible I am is
this another Photoshop battle that's
great
Hong Kong protest be like none know Kong
Kong would net Hong Kong would never
conquer would never I've seen this it's
so cute it's one of my favorite images
on the Internet
it's capturing the moment where an
actual dog goes mm-hmm
Karen left me oh no what Aurel leaves
I'm so confused
that's really cool but why but why hmm
but why yes I'm Patois Big Brain Academy
there's an actual game you can I want to
play that can you use the gun Pumped Up
Kicks intensifies I used to play Adam
lacrosse it with a rifle from my
Cavallo's game oh my god they have all
these mods and stuff why would you
anyone well boys time to dust up the old
we what is Big Brain Academy finally
they make a game for actual gamers Jesus
Lord save me
I'll be humming to another continent
Jesus that's right
oh that's so sad no oopsy doopsy woopsy
our blue screen made a boob seat a legit
well where you can also buy is the Ark
PD PI or a Kade Pack just go to arcade
games
you can get the same advantage hmm is
this captain minecraft what happened
it's like forbidden images oh my god I
want to pop the bottle bobble Bobble
really Felix
yes bobble why do I always feel like
someone stares at me when I am asleep I
don't understand why I wonder what the
cat is whispering satanic spells hello
John John wake up
you forgot my Planet Fitness anime
battle music intensifies megalovania
intensifies do did it dude that was a
straight-up home you know what
when water be like mmm I know why makes
me laugh so much Krispy Kreme it's so
bad was so good I love it
what no that has to be a Photoshop but
that's pretty snake be like a new
Christian mark its goos Wayne within
without the mask amazing whoa
flat-screen TV Wow this is dr. Phil man
I should do another dr. Phil seriously I
thought of three videos while making
this one but kid be like yeah I've seen
enough I had enough Internet I don't
need this anymore there's so much
happening I don't even know how to react
to this I took the time to make a Yuki
version a Loki wanna try that so how
many fries would you like yes yes sir
how many yes understood sir here you go
Burpo the guy from Fantastic Four was so
popular that made him in real life the
guy in the background going mmm do I
really want to work out to become like
that monster
this has a lot of our society raccoons
are awesome they're so cute
hmm look of guilt as out so good oh look
honey everybody's worth the same
lipstick you are you should probably
should buy it again that's embarrassing
what I was supposed to shoot the guy and
that's bad bad she's obviously trying to
eat the baby come on my sir would love
this image it looks so cute we always
send each other photos of inanimate
object that look like faces you get a
random picture of a housing you're like
what the hell is this oh hey delete this
delete this hmm that actually looks
comfy is how I would love to live there
me hiding from my problems am i right
stop him he's playing Minecraft IRL stop
him Oh mmm okay Kevin Hart next to the
rock the rock next to Shaq Shaq and next
to Chinese basketball player Jesus
Christ he must be massive actual size of
universe to scale finally we found
someone as tall as me I knew it why is
that so funny what time is it
mm-hmm oh it's my [ __ ] hmm don't do it
don't shoot it is that the yugioh card
that's pretty creative I'll hit that mmm
yeah modern fashion summarize right
there everyone I'll support your coming
along mm-hmm
oh my god is that one manga this hole
was made for him I wonder if my hole is
there too have you guys read that one
yeah it's Jun Jie Ito the creator was a
Maki read recommend reading this one if
you guys want to read something really
freaked you out this is my hole I'll
prove to you that this is my hole right
now just watch hey come back here
Oh God you've proved your point stop it
this is my hole this hole was made for
me I have to go in stop oh is that an
Audi
[Laughter]
good joke hmm the sundog the God of Sun
all hell oh you stinky Zoomers filled
with stink
someone stop that bad stop that's
illegal
I love the content face as well you
can't stop me and my two best friends
that's not him that's just impressive
why is there a toilet paper roll in
there mm-hmm
stop bet you stinky Zoomers fell for
that one didn't you back in my day we
had to actually walk up the stairs when
you take P P after B pee in poop boy am
i right gamers gamers know what I'm
saying
hey at least communism is good for one
thing look at that why did this offends
me to my very core
I'm not humming at this I refuse to hear
my days the Council of water they exist
I know it did he graduate that's the
real question
this is this gets dumber and dumber the
further we go mm-hmm is that in the
voting booth
mm-hmm guess I'll die oh my god that's
the best pumpkin carving I've ever seen
I love it oh my god I took me so long
hmm I thought for sure it was a giant
dog deep in the Minecraft jungle you
never know what you're gonna get is that
Christmas decorations seriously
know what happened there oh god oh no
not while I'm eating candy it's really
good
alright gamers it's been my pleasure to
be humming with you today if you enjoyed
smash like subscribe merch time merch
time game PewDiePie pics link what we're
all excited about the new game that's
coming out and I can't wait to play it
it starts with the letter P can you
guess what it is here with the pie pick
ceiling of course what you thought it
was Pokemon dumbass you stinky brainer
[Music]